it's about empathy and about totally
being able to understand how
somebody else feels whether that's a
candidate a client
you know anybody i think that is number
one
priority great recruiters can do that
i think it is not a great recruiter and
that's somebody who's purely driven by
you know a placement or priority by a
fee and i know that's probably
anti-recruiter isn't it but in my mind
the best people that i've worked with
have got a really high emotional
intelligence and i don't i don't look
back
and and have things that i should have
done differently is that really bad
set up with this really clear purpose
and that is something that i think if
anybody is setting up
that would be what i i would advise you
know
people to come up with and to stick by
and i get over excited about
maybe having this bigger business or
having a perception of this bigger
business and i had an added head count a
bit too soon
from we set up in january 19 um
and you know our sales built month on
month right up until
february um this year
i felt as i had a bit of a duty to
people to you know
to show strengths and to show positivity
and to show
[Music]
innovation